hello everyone and welcome to another
one of those games where everything that
could have gone wrong does go wrong and
um it's also from round one of the Tata
still India Blitz section uh nihal sarin
versus Hikaru Nakamura and interestingly
uh there are no 2 800 players in this
tournament only 2 700 players and 2900
players Hikaru is 2909 and everyone else
is 2700 something so let's dive straight
into it uh there's quite a lot to enjoy
here it's a long game but most of the
game uh is uh just shuffling pieces
around so basically it's it's the
opening that's important and what
happens in the end so anyhow with the
white pieces opens with the D4 we have
Knight to F6 Knight to F3 we have D5
sort of mixing it around some sort of a
Queen spawn opening and now C3 and pawn
to A5 that pretty much every other move
has been played here other than A5 and
this is what Hikaru plays and it is now
already as of move three that we have a
completely new game what's the point of
A5 you you might ask well of course it's
the stop B4 so Bishop to F4 going for a
London setup a bishop to F5 we have E3
E6 and now Pawn to A3 white of course
wants to advance the pawn to A4 uh C6
and now Pawn to C4 uh we have Knight B
to D7 by Hikaru and Knight the C3 with
Bishop to E7 and H3 now uh if you if
you're not following the event or if you
haven't seen the previous video nikal
actually won the rapid section with
seven and a half points so he's now
going into the the blitz section of the
event as the the winner of the former
event well of course once you accomplish
that everyone will uh will have more
respect for you and be more afraid of
you when they're playing against you so
H6 with Bishop to E2 and now the
characters and C4 Bishop captures and
Castle so some very very standard Queen
spawn uh opening stuff here we have
castles and not Knight the D5 uh again a
nice idea trying to trade off as many
pieces as possible and now Bishop to H2
you want to Black the capture and C3 so
you can capture B captures on C3 you do
not want to capture with the Knight or
with the bishop so Bishop back to H2 and
of course you don't want to allow Knight
captures on uh F4 uh B5 now advancing
the pawn attacking the bishop Bishop D3
and here Hikaru trades captures captures
and queen to B6 now uh developing the
queen connecting Rooks we have Rook F
the C1 and now Rook a to C8
maybe with some C5 ideas at some point
Queen back to E2 we have Queen to B7 and
Knight to E4 now going for that D6
Square as the bishop also covers that uh
Rook F to d8 and now the immediate
Knight to D6 attacks the queen and the
Rook so you have to trade here Bishop
captures Bishop captures and pawn to A4
so now a bishop and Knight versus two
knights uh it's hard to say which is
better but as all of the pawns are on
lights whereas the bishop is free to
roam in between the dark squares uh the
bishop should be a little bit better
here so Knight to D2 uh and now knight
seven to B6 with Bishop to C5 now uh as
the bishop was attacked and D6 and
Knight back to F6 with Rook the C2 and
Knight B to D7 we have Bishop to E7 and
The Rook the E8 and like I said even
though the bishop is better uh maybe
it's a little bit easier to play with
the knights in a Blitz game usually they
say Okay Bishop is better than Knight
and especially if it's an open game then
Bishop is better than night but in Blitz
night is almost always better than
Bishop so Bishop captures an F6 Knight
captures and Rook 8 to C1 uh C6 Pawn is
a is a backwards uh weak Pawn so of
course the nehal will now go after the
spawn and Hikaru has to defend it with
Ponte E5 Hikaru tries to go for some
tactics and this should uh just lose him
the game or or give nihal maybe a
winning Advantage but nihal misses it he
trusts Hikaru and he plays Knight to F3
I had the way to exploit this is to
actually capture on E5 uh and it's it's
funny because after captors and The Rook
captures there's Knight to F3 which
tempo as Now The Rook is attacked and it
doesn't matter where you put the rock
Rook D5 for example Knight D4 and now
this Pawn will fall that's the point and
you cannot Advance it as now the Knight
end the queen are attacking the B5 Pawn
so that's the way to do this but nihal
trusted Hikaru Knight to F3 knife to D7
and now D captures an E5 we trade
everything in the center here captures
captures captures and the queen to F3
again going for that C6 Pawn Rook the E6
nicely defending so you can see that now
black has no problems defending this
Pawn uh in the line that we've shown
there was no way to defend the pawn we
have rooked the D2 now Shifting the
Rooks to the open D file Queen to C7 and
Rook C to D1 we have Rook to E7 Rook to
D6 now uh very nice Rook lift and pawn
to C5 now Hikaru says he will push B 4
and then try to create a pass Pawn as he
does have a pawn advantage on the queen
side Queen to D5 now tripling up on the
D file and pawn to B4 uh we have Queen
to C4 and Rook to B8 now uh we have
Queen to A6 and the B captures an A3 B
captures an A3 and queen to C8 now
offering a queen trade but Queen
captures an A4 and now Pawn to see for
Hikaru sacrificed one Pawn so he can
start advancing his past C Pawn to
Victory uh which is very hard to deal
with especially in Blitz when you have a
little time on the clock so Rook to d8
with check and also by playing C4 Hikaru
offers a queen for two Rooks which you
should never do but for some reason
nihal thought that it's a good idea and
maybe even because it's Blitz maybe it's
hard to coordinate the queen then the
two rocks and he goes for it Rook to d8
with the check Queen captures Rook
captures and now uh Rook captures on the
eight and queen captures and C4 so it
looks for the queen Plus snehal grabs
the pass pawn and now it's queen and the
past a pawn versus the two Rooks but of
course the Rooks only need to double up
and the pawn will be won so uh that that
pawn is it doesn't really exist so Rook
to A8 we have Pawn to A4 and not just
the Rook e to A7 now Hikaru will win the
pawn G4 and now Ponte H5 trying to mess
up the pawn structure King to G2 and now
Rook captures an A4 we have Queen to D5
H captors and G4 now if you capture The
Rook will capture also so Pawn to H4 and
now it's going to be very hard to prove
that the queen can do anything here
Against The Rook so Rook 4. at the at
the A6 uh Queen to E4 and now Rook to d8
with Ponte H5 and now uh Hikaru goes for
Rook to H6 Rook to F6 was much much
stronger it goes after the F2 pawn and
it's not easy to defend this point is
that after Queen B4 stopping Rook D2 you
will play Rook D5 going after the pawn
and now it doesn't matter what you do
here if King G3 let's say Rook F3
checking captures through captors and F2
the white king is now wide in the open
black will be uh well quick to win this
game so after H5 Hikaru goes for Rook to
H5 and now okay Queen captures on G4 now
it's not as bad Rogue back to F6 now
he's going for it but now Hikaru just uh
goes for Queen before he stops Rook to
D2 uh sorry nihal stops Rook to D2 We
have rooked the D5 by Hikaru going after
the H5 pawn and queen to B8 with check
King H7 Queen to B1 with check and King
the H6 now even this is possible Pawn to
F4 and now Rook captures an H5 so now
the two Rooks will try to harass the
white king queen to B8 and now King back
to H7 we have Queen to B1 with check
Rook to G6 now and the F5 doesn't really
do anything since uh once once you uh
uh well uh once white makes a move after
check uh F5 doesn't really do all that
much but black stops it with Pawn to F5
either way because it might it might be
a bit problematic so here Queen to B4 we
have rooked the H3 with check King to E2
and now Rook to E6 putting pressure on
the E3 pawn and now nihal uh is in a
really really bad situation Queen to C5
was played now Rook H captures on E3 and
now you cannot give the queen back for
two Rooks if you do this then at the
position is completely winning for black
the two pawns will overcome the white
Pawn uh so instead after Rook captures
King to F2 and now we have Rook to E2
with check King F1 and now King the G6
sorry King to G6 now he caramely has to
figure out how to uh defeat the white
king in in in the most uh in the
simplest of ways but as you'll see
that's easier said than done we have
Queen to G one with the check King to F7
and now Queen the A7 with check Rook D7
blocking and queen to C5 we have G6 by
Hikaru and now Queen to D5 with check uh
King to G7 Queen to D4 with check King
to H7 and the queen to F6 now we have
Rook to the E4 uh going after the F4
Pawn with check King to G2 and now Rook
the B7 now at this point it's defended
maybe you can even Checkmate the the
white king here Queen to C6 and now Rook
to DQ with check with King the G3 and
now the position is completely winning
for Hikaru but he first has to hide his
King he has to put the king to safety
instead he goes Rook to D3 check right
away and Incredibly incredible as it is
the position is a draw now King to H4
and there's no way to win this look at
this if you try King to H6 now there's
the spectacular Queen captures on G6
with check and after King captures this
is now stalemate so now of course hikar
will not fall for that but there isn't
anything else to try if you play Rook
captures an F4 which changes King G5 and
again it's a draw now the black king is
even close to getting checkmated and if
you try something like Ru G4 check King
F6 uh there's no way to continue if Rook
D4 just Queen to C7 with check and you
might even lose the game here
uh King H6 Queen to each do check and
you get checkmated that's just the way
it is you have to give up both of the
black Rooks and that's Checkmate so
instead after King H4 Rook to D1 was
played by Hikaru now comes King to G5 uh
Rook Dita E1 doubling up and now Queen
captures and G6 King h8 we have Queen to
F6 with tracking the G8 and now Queen to
G6 repeating the position a little bit
king f8 queen captures an F5 now nihal
wins that pawn now he again has a pass
pawn and uh he will try pushing it so
King to G8 we have Queen to G6 checking
the f8 queen to F6 checking to Jade
Queen to G6 checking to f8 Queen to D6
checking to F7 and now Queen to D5 with
check King G7 Queen to D7 check Rook to
E7 and now Queen to D4 with check King
to F7 and only Now Pawn to F5 uh so you
you will be able to push F6 attack The
Rook also looking from D4 guards G1 so
there are no checks here Rook the 8 by
Hikaru Queen to D5 with checking to f8
with King the F6 now threatening
checkmate with Queen to F7 and here
Hikaru played Rook 1 to E7 but now the
position is completely winning for nihal
but you have to find the correct idea uh
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for nihal while I give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that
black is in complete suktuang and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show the movie is Queen to C5 or D6 it's
only important to put the queen on this
diagonal so Queen to C5 this is what
nihal played and he was in this position
on move 87 that Hikaru Nakamura resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here he cannot move anything if you
move this Rook then Queen captures an E7
this Rook cannot move at all and of
course if you move the king then uh
that's also a problem just Queen
captures and E7 Rook captures King
captures and you are now free to advance
your past Pawn to Victory so truly a
spectacular game nihal went for a very
odd decision but uh seemingly uh it it
uh it might be the the best course of
action in The Blitz game like it might
be easier to coordinate the Queens but I
always imagine it would be easier to
coordinate the the two Rooks in short
time control but yeah here he he defeats
none other than the speed demon Hikaru
Nakamura which is absolutely incredible
and he was lost he was dead lost for the
entire game but he just you know
persevered and uh came came out on top
incredible stuff by nihal and what a
position to end the game Queen C5 uh
absolutely spectacular something you
would print out and put on your wall or
you know on your refrigerator or on the
back of your car uh really a spectacular
position uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it uh like I said if
you have any other games that you would
like to see feel free to use hashtag
suggestion many of them are being played
so I will go over them I already have
one that I really enjoy so I will do
that one next but uh you know feel free
to suggest uh so once again really hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Stefan trifunovich Andres
zolton sarkari and Eric Adams for a
contribution to my channel Channel I
think a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Tata steel India Blitz
Edition until it finishes uh thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day